Lucan Becca here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we're gonna take you
to the past back to 2007 me and Rebecca
went to southern India to visit my
parents they were living there and
working as missionaries for our church
and we visited spent about nineteen days
and it was absolutely amazing and we're
gonna take you along for the ride
Becca for years has been asking me to
take this old footage and put it
together into a video and and so here it
is and we're gonna give you our
commentary over the top so come with us
back to 2007 before children before I
was doing YouTube and enjoy the ride
here we are Becca and I have just bought
tickets to India $4,600 in
non-refundable airfare I was back in law
school this was our one bedroom
apartment in Crystal City Virginia back
when I was going to George Mason for Law
School
it was really stressful buying the
tickets though they were expensive yeah
that was a lot of money for us
yeah that was a lot of money but we're
like when are we ever to get to go and
visit my parents in India again anyway
35 hours on a plane and we were crashing
on my parents floor and oh it was such a
crazy ride I to getting over there hi
this is here we are Bangalore India
here's mom and over there that right
there is a little boy who just hit her
with the soccer ball but this is this is
really actually we visit a lot of just
little parks and just drove around the
city I mean there were no tourists there
I mean it Bangalore is not a touristy
place and it's a beautiful city but so
many nice people people that are just
amazing okay but look at look at this
this is this is some foreshadowing for
my my days of the catfish conference
here I was just basically signing
autographs and taking photos with people
only they would do that with all of us
any because we were like it was Tom yeah
tall white people they would say oh my
goodness I want a picture with you and
then we just get mobbed by people who
wanted to take their photo with us what
are graphs like so it was kind of like
being a celebrity without being a
celebrity the most entertaining thing in
the world to do in India is to drive
down the road scary it's just so so much
to see okay if you see this gal right
there in the orange and white behind my
sister she was they were stalking us
it turns out they came out and I wanted
to take our pictures like here they are
like I wanted to get pictures no nothing
usual but later on in the park the the
mom and dad came up and it took
daughter and just like dropped or right
next to me and they just like ran for
they like ding dog ditched their
daughter like I think they wanted wanted
to do like some arranged marriage or
crap because they just like drop drop
and ran for it and we had to go
sprinting after them and chase them down
and give them their daughter back and
I'm late no no you'll marry married very
here very nice lady I'm sure but you
know ain't gonna work oh gosh
number two we jokingly yeah his wife
number two so Airy Christmas morning uh
uh
we woke up my sister by jumping on her
and given her like a piledriver or
something you know oh we had a great
time this is such that was so much fun
just really hang out with the family and
India but my parents were in charge of
all the missionaries in India Sri Lanka
parts of Nepal and stuff like that so on
Christmas which really isn't a huge
holiday in India they'd have all the
missionaries over and they my mom made
like a you know western-style breakfast
for them anyway oh but here on Christmas
day we went down to the mall and that is
where I bought my India cricketing
Jersey which you have probably seen in
lots of my videos you know 13 years all
the reason why it looks I'm in Mills
office since this is mill sitting is to
smile a smile he's working hard he's
very busy
[Music]
yeah here's the mission home this is as
kind of the headquarters for the
missionaries in India or then they split
became southern India
we're gonna go China find
a place for loops Mumbai cricket bat
[Music]
we're the auto and we're we're his
downtown just Burroughs gotta watch the
driving down the road was the most
entertaining thing in India I just you
see the craziest stuff like like two
guys and six coats on a scooter you know
or you know a car 18-wheeler would be
flipped over you know or just like in
the middle of road and like nobody doing
anything about it it was just it was
chaotic it's scary and fascinating at
same time oh and these were the creepy
Santa's they a whole bunch of guys
dressed up when they like the most like
horror fiction Santa masks such
interesting stores yeah this antique
shop I bought a bunch of like spear
heads and weapons for like five bucks I
bought like a couple hundred year old
spear I love the flower markets they
smelled so good oh yeah this it was just
India was one of the most interesting
places we've ever traveled and traveled
a lot of places then we jumped up to
delis we're in Bangalore and then we
flew to Delhi yes this is in Delhi where
I did I know it's a cliche but I got
Delhi Belly in Delhi yeah yeah it's I am
your host Luke Nicholson I'm going to be
explaining how Indian toilets working
who the lectionary aunty ones okay
toilet paper is a Western invention so
what you do is you raise the seat you
sit down and you're done you rinse off
I've got a dad side coat eating a
motorcycle tire here we are for temple
there's little bartering for something
so we have been on vacation for one week
now oh it's not like you've had bread a
World Heritage Site what's what's the
name of this place again
well my older daughter Oh
[Music]
there's our kites
yeah that's india gate which is kind of
like their world war ii memorial which
is really really gorgeous the dude with
the Sten machine gun that was cool yes
Gandhi's - it's also in Delhi I keep
wanting to yell out myself hold the
camera still yeah yeah our camera work
leaves much to be desired
this is the Red Fort it was gorgeous I
mean these places are huge and just
amazing they're mind-blowing palaces and
yeah we've been to castles all over
Europe and palaces all over Europe this
stuff is like yeah this is so much
bigger yeah
the Rakshasa melody was so jammed in
there it was so uncomfortable
yeah yeah I mean they're they're they're
electrical work and it is sketchy on a
on a massive scale
it is it's a big rat's nest of wires the
may or may not be live yeah and crazy
monkeys yeah
highway is just was just crazy haha okay
my uncle Jean had a pet monkey that bit
his freakin the ear off and that is all
I'm thinking about right now is his
monkey jumped on back on my deck away -
hold still
don't bite my ear off my boobies - away
see what yeah I can for 500 rupees okay
Mandy made here's these people just
bailing out of the back of a truck in
front of us on a like six eight-lane
highway and there's me riding a camel
white white on the campus well this is
Becca Nichol riding a camel on the way
the Taj Mahal way to the camera
[Music]
so the Taj Mahal live you've seen
pictures of it the Taj Mahal is amazing
but it's this one building inside a
massive amazing complex it's it's huge
absolutely huge and it's you know it
looks white because it's all marble and
and the rest is this red sandstone you
know but you look at the surface of the
Taj Mahal is just covered in all this
inlay this semi-precious stones
yeah it's funny you see the pictures of
it I never even realized there's
decoration on the outside it always gets
my fly but yeah
here we are at the church and kgs India
church the next day the small mining
town called kgf and there was a gal who
got baptized on the roof of the building
and we went to the baptism that was kind
of cool we're now back in southern India
and yeah this is southern India this is
this is a banyan tree this is on the way
to my sword and there's Becca bunches of
monkeys in this park you can see them
and my kids are traumatized with stories
of uncle James monkeys I like my hair
okay
Mysore holds a special place in my heart
because this is where I truly learned to
barter like I like it clicked it clicked
in Mysore and it was New Year's Eve and
after we went around and saw this palace
I went off to the markets by myself and
just bought whatever I could just to
barter as much as possible and and the
gals went and saw this these big
fountains and stuff and then we all met
up back at the hotel for Christmas for
New Year's
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
I look at all the staffs out here just
blowing crap off
[Music]
then put fire in there firework
distancing from the China convinced leak
standoff
these two bulls are fighting their herd
of cows I remember the Bollywood music I
remember I went and bought a whole bunch
of Bollywood albums in a music store and
a cow was inside the music store and
just like pissing all over the floor
here know where we're at Kabini river
lodge is this really cool lodge on the
Kabini river is that National Park in
southwest India okay so at the lodge I
got a board and the driver I was like
Hayes what was to do around here he say
when we go visit that these remote
jungle schools I make sure let's do that
so we went to this like little mud huts
like convenience store literally mud hut
convenience store and I bought up all
the school surprise they had in the
whole village like 30 bucks or something
and we went down to schools and just
handed out pens and papers and so all
the kids did a little performance and
came up they wanted to practice their
English the teacher wanted to do like
photo ops like this is like yeah a lot
of people would hold your hands in India
is like hand-holding between bedrooms
like the total thing over there
Oh God lean on this girl Nina d0 thank
you okay goodbye
yes I learned the cricket last week shut
down the school for like 30 minutes to
shake hands with the white guy handing a
ballpoint ballpoint pens it was weird
but I had a great time we got to go into
Safari yes it was so inconsistent with
our videos do this is old school cameras
no no digital stabilizers no anti shake
yeah
yeah we saw we saw probably half a dozen
Indian elephant type I didn't include
all the footage in here there was a lot
of a lot of video from this dysentery
but we saw a lot of cool animals yeah we
didn't see a tiger and we didn't see a
leopard but just about everything else
that's a jungle chicken so these were
the elephant's trunk people around
[Music]
[Music]
anything you give it put it in the river
and and the girls everyone else went on
the powerboat and then they had this
giant wicker basket with a blue tarp
underneath it called a coracle boat
they're like do you want to go on that I
think yeah that looks sketchy I want to
be a part of that I'm pretty sure they
were a crocodile-infested there were
crocodiles we saw we saw some crocodiles
but yeah that's me that's a giant whisk
wicker basket and they've just put like
six layers of like plastic bags and
tarps underneath it and there wasn't
that much leaking yeah I keep saying I
need to do a video about making a
coracle boat that was just holding
really still up like this thing is tippy
and I am big it put like four indian
guys in the other boat and just be that
was a big vent why do we we're keeping
him by himself so here we go that was a
cool lodge I was really excited about
the jungle chickens all right and then
suddenly we're in Sri Lanka
okay this was during the civil war in
Sri Lanka like my parents were working
in Sri Lanka and in this hotel earlier
when there was like a suicide plane
attack and my dad was in the bathroom
like cold heavily hey yeah there's
anti-aircraft fire out the window there
[ __ ] they're shooting planes down out
here you know
oh my goodness this is so beautiful
there's all the people falling in the
fishnet
in search of an elephant's ride I really
wanted elephant you said that like a
Travel Show before we went to India like
somebody riding on the beach on an
elephant and we're like we're doing that
and and we we did when it takes to ride
an elephant on a beach in Sri Lanka yeah
that was way cool it was yeah I was just
gorgeous
those beautiful beach and we're writing
it outside on the beach as awesome
yeah it was like 10 bucks or so the
elephant's gotten in trouble because it
was pulling off some of the land
speaking for the hotel
look at how beautiful this is and look
how beautiful my wife is I wish we had
to sell hurry back we had like five
minutes to go put our cows in the water
and go a swim for like three minutes
then dry up and get back in the car we
had flew back thirty five hours back
home yeah yeah yeah I was good to wait
hopefully you guys enjoyed watching this
thanks for watching click subscribe
we'll see you next Saturday if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]